hello everyone uh good day science life
I don't know where you are located in
I'm in Brazil so it's good morning here
uh
just a moment I will put my phone in
Focus mode
okay
uh so this stock is about file transfer
as you can see uh
so it may it makes two things that I
like and with this art and python
so let's let's start up and I'm Isaac uh
I'm a software engineer
let's let's present myself
I bought in Brazil and I'm leaving
here in Brazil actually in Fortaleza
with is which is a
City in the north east of the country
uh
it's working on by uh his work known by
the beats and some Travelers and for her
and a lot of songs in Brazil
um a master's student at Federal
University of Sierra
in database skilled in
in my
my
my rich Stitch area is natural language
processing so
it's
I'm at the beginning so when I enjoyed I
did not had some so much experience in
this area it's like a challenge to me
but I'm like I'm learning a lot so
and I'm a hit Searcher it's inside data
science lab it's a lab inside my
University
so last part of my Master's Degree I had
to read a lot of Articles and do some
research to my
my paper presentation next year
so this lab is helping me with that and
I'm professionally I'm a I'm a software
engineer
a consultant at squadra it's a
consultant company here in Brazil
uh
besides python I have experiencing with
blood
with mobile mobile development and free
stack development with uh dotnet and in
Java
so uh a little about myself I really
love coffee so I
I had a entire
I'm sorry space for coffee here and I
visit a lot of coffee shops in Port
Elizabeth
and I love astronomy too
it's something that I like to study
and with
uh terrorist the recent Advance we have
a lot to to study and and to observe
uh
and I'm a Star Wars celebrate
let's
let's come to the Jedi side of the force
starting
uh when we talk about uh this is very
diff it's very difficult to Define ah
because
uh which we something that is actually
was not art
yesterday or in the past in the past
decade or it's in the past Century
we can provide us example
the Vanguard print entries with
uh in the time that when God was alive
was not so
it was not so considered art by some
some people and today it's a very very
you know
you know piece of art
so this concept Vara is a long time
uh
but we came
we can Define uh uh using Oxford
Dictionary
uh the variable good through
construction without constants meaning
so this could differ tomorrow
and we can Define tool as uh
activities linked to manifestations
often aesthetically or communicative
naturally
so
if I if I want to communicate something
about
what I'm feeling or what about my
reality or about my work I can make a
chemical
painting or a scripturally or
something
different
and present to other people in this will
be considered act or not not today
and so uh we have a example of this
picture of Fountain of Marcel of the
shame uh
uh
work of data is School
so
we some at another school was a rupture
with
see all those schools of art so
me
made some piece of art this very
different to uh
what the people was was used to see
so this Zone example of art
I guess this was not doing it they
realized those
works
so another question we can make just
humans can produce art uh I can see you
writing if you're writing something but
you can answer it to yourself
so let's proceed
uh well I
I can't answer if those humans can
can make make art because I'm
uh I'm not a
specialist yeah I'm just a admire
but I can make some opinions and
uh I think we can we can
experiment let's experiment with those
things and uh this year
to use work of Json Allens uh Last of Us
AI generated art to own a price
so
this work is naming
territory the doctor is special
in
it was the first the first place scene
that the Colorado State Fair
and this
this winning uh
starter uh started uh
started uh
started a new trend about
generating art by AI
we started transfer is not it's not
something new this is
I think we have 10 years or 20 years
of X distance but into recent years it
got
the all of us
and
this year with this
price we got uh
the main attention of some of some
people and some artists who are some
people disagree this is
art and some agree and we have this
discussion until today and I think this
question
we have a lot to to
deserve
so
what is file transfer how can you define
that
uh we have some system services
of
AI
in
filters in something you can put your
photo in someday I will do some work in
the following you you will look like uh
I mean
piece of art or you can we have we had
this year the value of lengths at you
that sure is AI and it's something that
got viral
so we had we had a lot of
Technologies like face app
in
I forgot to what the technology that I
was going to talk but we you just you
made a Google and
do a Google Android we will find a lot
of these Technologies so it's something
very present uh at all all days
and what if we were possible to apply
the style of Vanguard painting through a
bottle for Sunset that you to go to get
your phone or
yourself or the bottom of your cat you
can yes you can uh it's possible now
so basically we try to separate what is
Style and what it's content of the image
so we have you had
we must have two images one for a style
so
in this example I I forgot to remove the
grid and I'm sorry for that but in this
example I use it uh Starry Night of as
my style
and I
use it this Sunset victory of a city in
near to fertilizer here and where I I
was traveling
and I took this photo and this photo is
my content
so what is the style the style is the
color patterns shade of brush Strokes uh
the decking the technique use it
uh
everything that may
the painting his self
so the content is something different
something different
every Potter you can imagine
so
when you have a style image but I we
recall a in any image for transcript we
call the we can transfer this type of B
modifying the content
uh but sorry we don't modify the
quantity by modifying the image a
applying this this style
so what we have to present we have to
present the content
uh
so let's
let's move on
and we
this is possible we have a lot of
of
we have a different way of doing style
transfer now since we have gas networks
but this presentation will focus on
convolutional neural networks but yes
you can do is different without using
convolution
but many of algorithms are based on
convolution networks and we have this
work here in
2015. as a great working one of the
great works in the field of
convolutional networks for startup
transfer
was a
uh
some of the first Works in this area and
I'm sorry on of the first most read and
impact in Impact Works in this area was
not I
I believe was not the first one
so how convolution neural networks
worked uh
so convolutionary language consist of
planes of small computation units that
process visual information Miracles
so what are you what are you talking is
that uh we have a image as an input
and
the CNN I I
abbreviate that
uh the CNN will look
into this for this Victory and we will
apply some filters
uh I have a picture of filters in the
next slides but
this DC Union we apply some computers in
this
Matrix in this Matrix
so every every image will be transformed
in The Matrix because every
uh
we
the eyes are often
see this everything has a very number of
made twists so
if image will be not different
so
the CNN we will look
add some
at some pieces of my image and we look
for some patterns and some
for
yeah some buttons and we will indeed
fight this buttons and this will happen
here actually so we have this
convolution layer that will notify
something and pass to the author and
this and we will follow the flow we want
to we have a
identifier of this pixel
so as here we have a mouse Victory and
of Duties will identify this part of the
victory with a crew
so
uh tip we have some filters and for
example the filters we will begin here
and we didn't fight that I don't know if
you're seeing my mouse but I
I you keep so I
I we need to fight the first
uh
part of of the victory until I see this
this queue here and
are you when you identify something
different are you my CNN will
uh
apply some math math things to this to
this picture
so
this is how CNN will understand and we
see the world
everything is is Matrix
so how is Magic flows
well
Teresa as I explained it before there's
a lot of ways of you do style Transit
and you can use tensorflow Hub too to
your
made something
to transfer some
to your play and you just translate
something very fast to another picture
and you can use something
some architectory and you can use uh
this this architectures to do some work
for you
so when you in this experiment we use
vtg 19.
you can use vdg texting you know haznet
or everything you want
uh and
we have to has two images so as I input
to
to our Network so in this example we
have a this cat image as a content and
we have uh this art Victory as style I
forgot the name of designs I'm sorry
I think it's the grid
the grid tsunami or something like that
uh
I I clothe the Brazilian name but I
don't know the English name of this of
this these are
uh
and
we
we extract this type of
of this architecture to all Targets
English
um
the final result or the final output is
the target image it's called let's call
it targets so it's the final war is the
final
result of all Network
so we transformed the image into
numerical matrices as I said as I said
the networks will see Matrix matrices
and numbers so they will you have to
pass this to matrices
uh
and we we have to extract the features
of the other information of this image
we have to compute the ground gram
matrices is
if you don't know what is gram matrices
you don't have to worry is this math is
math you just have to
to
uh get the height to weight and I think
the depth of your image and you multiply
you may see by his transpose so when you
have this information you just have to
multiply this matrices matrix by the
suppose of this matrix it's uh it's a
formula you just have to
put in code
and we have you will do this for each
layer in the style image
before we have we set the widths for
each time laying and for content
and uh
at the final step we update the target
image and calculate losses
so one way of do that
show me the code
uh
we have we
we already selected the images and we
are let's selected the architecture so
this is just the
the
workflow of two inches type transfer
look don't worry if you don't understand
that at principle is a lot of
it's a lot of
definitions then it's uh we try to do
this we try to keep this talk as
introductor to that field
so
in the one two three one to five lines
we have a
number of steps in the five five in the
fall line and in the line three we set
Adam as optimizer
so you will you have we
we
[Music]
uh
getting uh for Loop so we get
Target features in the line eight
uh
and we calculate the content loss of in
the line 10 so this is just a map
another map calculation you have to
calculate the square of the difference
of the package features in the in this
convolution layer in the content
features in this same convolution layer
so in this type of in this next step we
will calculate the style loss
and uh
so we
get a package featuring for that layer
that we we uh
that we are in in the interaction so as
I said we will get the depth height and
weight in the line 50.
and in the lines everything we will get
the gray Matrix for this layer
and
uh on 19 to 22 to 22 we populate the
style loss
uh in 25 we calculated total loss if is
the style weight
much time style loss was
constantly times content loss
so this is the step
and we
move move forward to the next step since
we have
two thousand steps to to
say
and I just made a
31 to 35 in this middle plots a very
a very
uh
500 stop steps we we plot how home image
is is going if it is not it's not
beginning to
to be a great image we can start stop
the execution and populate the
parameters or just select new images
and move forward
so we have some examples here that I was
experimenting the first image is a name
here in Brazil it's the star guy trying
to fight with a gate
and we have a bakuru that is uh
yeah yeah sorry to interrupt
um since we run out of time already
ready
okay I'm just finished
um
so I have the
I would not describe the English sorry
just because of the time but making we
get that was not a good what's a good
image
we have uh